saucier ça si vous voulez dire
virez salon ils ont réduit - res a
demandé sa cause de la vente des petits
avions avis d'expulsion du travail ou
celle du travail
j'en tire les conclusions en décidant de
mettre enfin la fonction présidentielle
[Musique]
contre moi votre stylo votre stylo bille
super outre les quatre soldats français
je peux d'illégal impute à des
animateurs tard
bien des oueds les réserves ni que
d'autres peuvent savoir
voilà vous pensez pas que michel
montaigne premier ministre ce serait une
chance formidable pour la france une
invitation à dîner et laurent roussel et
nous on en prendrait pas part à 10 ans
ben on sent vous préviens c'est lui des
avis et désobéissant dans soyons résolu
de ne plus servir et nous serons enfin
libres trouve quand même qu'on devrait
tous avoir droit à un minimum de bonne
guerre
[Musique]